not necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
and you would vote again to fire dr
jarrah first thing on the agenda is my
opinion more important than yours
can i hear you out
this week on politics now from school
violence to graduation rates we speak
with candidates in one of the most hotly
contested clark county school board
races this year
aiming for qualified candidates a group
of former ccsd trustees described their
mission to shape the school board
plus republican senate candidates sam
brown and adam laxalt debate for the
first time
[Music]
from 8 news now
this is politics now
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler three
members of the clark county school board
those seats are up for grabs this year
the seats are for president irene cepeda
linda cavazos and danielle ford all
three were at the center of the
superintendent being fired then rehired
last year so this week we are digging
into those races and we start with
trustee ford and what happened with the
superintendent
what was it that motivated you to
motivate the
maybe other trustees but specifically
you
to
terminate his contract
um big picture he no specifically i'm
trying to get an idea
maybe some parents already know this but
like specifically what was it about his
what is it about his his uh
his time in office and his work that
encouraged you to terminate his contract
to vote that way the thing that i put on
the record um is that
i have knowledge the board has knowledge
of ways that he's treated his cabinet
and their claims of him harassing
bullying intimidating threatening and
extorting them
and the way that we did that vote
per his contract he can be terminated
for convenience which just means that
the board doesn't all have to come up
with one reason
and prove it to be a reason for cause
anyone who has watched school board
meetings for the last several years will
have seen disputes
quite somewhat vicious ones i think uh
on the school board diocese during
meetings
name calling
in public
and
do you believe that that decorum by
yourself and other board members is the
best way to handle the education at the
heart of what you're
elected to
work on and do
sure i've heard that argument a bunch of
those concerns about the
you know way that certain board members
i would assume myself included in that
one
acts on the dais and
while i agree with that to an extent you
know i believe that my constituents
trust that i'm doing what i feel is
right
and a lot of what i do or say on the
dais is based on things that i've seen
and experienced
behind the scenes so there are trustees
that are bullies right bullies and one
of the situations in which i called
someone a name and that name was a phony
bologna
okay
what they didn't see was her leaning
behind another trustee
calling me names
you know while i'm trying to
move progress forward and get a plan
together what can you do if you're
re-elected as a board member to
change discipline to improve discipline
to do something about
treating students with respect and
compassion if they do something wrong
but at the same time protecting them
we need to just bring in groups and
organizations who understand our
community and who want to work with the
schools we should be do allowing
principals to
find out who those people are
get them you know background checked
allowed to come into the schools and do
it we don't we're not letting people
into our schools to help because it's
either
adopt this you know national expensive
curriculum professional development
that's going to tell you
things to say or bring people from other
districts to do it
instead of just saying like hey this is
all hands on deck
we need the community to help and figure
this out we just need to trust our
principals and our teachers and let them
do the job that they're experts at
broadly speaking if you're re-elected
the biggest issue at clark county
schools district that you want to
address right away it's teacher
retention and
it's staff retention it's not it's not
the amount of teachers
it's not
i'm frustrated that the only metric that
we're even
able to evaluate
is how many new teachers we get well
new teachers are big business you know
new teachers cost a lot to recruit cost
a lot to train
we don't have the time to do that but we
still have a lot of teachers we talk
about the shortage
but we're not talking about the 16 17
000 teachers that we already have
so we should be doing everything to
retain them
before recruiting and if it was up to me
i would be doing some sort of campaign
like
please stay please come back can we give
you a re-signing bonus similar to the
military you know sign a four-year
contract we'll give you a bonus every
single year of that and you would vote
again to fire dr jarrah first thing on
the agenda
even if despite the fact that there's
still like ongoing litigation uh with
doctor jar i mean
no it's not the 2.6 million dollars that
hasn't been settled yet that's lingering
but it's been proven that nothing
happened it's been proven
i can't say exactly how that he has zero
claims and that it was all nonsense
nine people are challenging ford for her
district fc that includes former nevada
assemblywoman irene bustamante adams i
asked her why she's running and the
change that she wants at ccsd
what do you think clark county school
district and the board
needs the most right now i've heard
repeatedly and it's my personal opinion
too i think the
restoration of professionalism and trust
is at the top of the food chain
i met recently with one of the
principals in the school district and i
think he put it
best
the kids are watching us
they're watching the leaders and so we
have to be role models at every level
and so i would say the decorum the
civility
is definitely at the top of the list the
incumbent in district f is danielle ford
who was very vocal during that
experience she's been very vocal on the
school board from from the beginning of
her time serving on the with the board
of trustees um what is it about her
performance
and her actions on the and the board of
trustees that motivated you perhaps to
run for this position but was there
anything
um
i would say obviously the
professionalism and the the code of
conduct for how you treat your fellow
colleagues did play a role into it but
i've had a passion to serve in public
service ever since exiting the
legislature and i've volunteered and
continued to volunteer and so
i i have an inclination to want to serve
in public service the issue of violence
on campus not only among among students
but unfortunately against teachers saw
the horrible situation at el dorado high
school
the district had tried restorative
justice as sort of a an overarching
method within the district there's a bit
of change to that now what do you think
is the best way to handle violence
and discipline within the district i
think it has to be a comprehensive
approach so i do
believe in
no tolerance and i also believe in
restorative justice how can you do both
i think that we're not utilizing
everything that we have as far as a tool
and a resource here in the community and
what i mean by that is
students and teachers need to feel safe
but then what do you what's going on
with the student what's going on with
the family that have created the actions
there are tools like the harbor where we
do a wrap-around for the entire child
and the family to figure out and dig
deep a lot of the students are dealing
with
issues at home they're dealing with
homelessness they're dealing with
being sexually assaulted unfortunately
in their own household what's going on
how do we help the parents
what kind of resources can we give that
individual is it food insecurity and so
it has to be comprehensive should ccsd
be broken up
i think that it's a yes a conversation
on the table how we do it
matters
um it's hard to steer the ship in ccsd
it's like moving the titanic right and
so
you need to figure that out i don't know
the answer yet but i know that we could
have conversations to make sure that
there's access and equity for the
students
and for the teachers the lack of
teachers within clark county school
district they're leaving at a
concerning rate
the district has tried to bring in
substitutes they've kind of looked the
threshold's been lowered to allow more
people to try and step into the
classroom
i guess the first question is is that
the best way to go about filling the
shortage having people without college
degrees essentially help substitute
teach but more importantly what can be
done to get teachers back into the
classroom
i think i was sharing with you earlier
right i just went to a graduation from
nevada state college with a which is a
phenomenal institution and one of the
largest groups was
in education
so
i would say how how is that connection
happening how is dual credit happening
in order for us to grow our own
and so those are just some
some ideas
we have full interviews with danielle
ford and irene bustamante adams at
8newsnow.com they're both very long
interviews a group called the
conservative coalition has held school
board candidate forums last week they
had candidates for the district dc which
is held by trustee president irene
zepeda a major concern from the public
increased violence in schools cepeda
says the district needs long-term
solutions to curb the violence that
would include hiring more teachers
here's how her opponents brenda zamora
tavora elliot fernando romero and
stephen conger want to address the issue
there's a lot of bullying happening
addressing those bullying issues once
they're coming in you know
i know they're calling safe voices but
sometimes they're not being
responsive as quickly as they need to
what i would do to address that is to
increase the officer presence on campus
we need at least two officers on campus
we need to get
teachers involved we need to get parents
involved
in dealing with the issue involving the
community you will lessen
the violence different schools have
different
different needs different disciplinary
needs and part of the problem is those
disciplinary decisions have been taken
away from those schools
and we need to put that put those
decisions back into the hand
ccsd says changes have already been made
at el dorado high school where a teacher
was beaten and sexually assaulted
according to police last month
while the candidates try and earn votes
in the public there is one group working
behind the scenes to try and mold the
school board it's called abc pac the
organization is led by former school
board members terry jennison and sheila
moulton they say they're focused on
trustee demeanor and qualifications not
specific policies we talk with them
about who they're endorsing and why
in district d we're going to recommend
irene sepeta
in district f we're going to recommend
another irene hiring bustamante adams
and in district g which happens to be my
district we're recommending greg wyman
okay
what is it about those candidates that
stands out to you guys
so we have some criteria we what we've
chosen to do is not focus on specific
issues or policies but we looked at you
know can the person collaborate does the
person have the ability to be able to
work with others do you have an
understanding of budgets and of policy
and also do you have an understanding of
what the role of the trustee is because
i think some people come in and they
think well i'm going to run and i'm
going to just change that whole district
but the role of a trustee is to
set policy and regulation and hold the
superintendent accountable when a vote
goes down 4-3
can you work with it even if you don't
particularly like it have you discussed
it debated it decided and then you need
to support it
and that's sometimes hard for board
members to do there's issues of campus
safety recently obviously there was the
firing and rehiring of the
superintendent there's been a lot going
on
in and out of the classroom in and out
of the the
trustees uh meetings
from your perspective what
what is the direction for the district
right now
what is the direction forward you gotta
look at student achievement and student
safety and you've got to engage with the
superintendent like terry said the
superintendent is your one go-to man and
i remember years ago a
headhunter that came in to help us look
for a superintendent and said you're
good individual board members but you've
got to learn to work as a board and i
really think that that's
one of the most important things but
we've got to focus on the students and
we haven't seen a lot of that in the
board meeting
we'll have much more coverage of the
school board races at clark county
school district in next week's show
next on politics now separating
themselves how adam laxalt and sam brown
showed differences in their first
republican primary senate debate
and what happens when nevada ends its
coronavirus state of emergency
republican senate candidates adam laxalt
and sam brown faced off in their first
and so far only primary debate this week
they appeared on nevada newsmakers up in
reno brown accused laxalt of not doing
enough to stop election fraud during his
time as nevada's attorney general
2020 when president trump nevadans and
americans were relying on you to be the
one to challenge any sort of issues with
the 2020 election the only thing you did
was to file a lawsuit that per your own
admission was late the secretary of
state in this state is in charge of
elections in charge of investigations
and so
you know the bottom line i was just as
appointed as the next person
president trump lost nevada by more than
33 thousand votes in the last
presidential election nevada republican
secretary of state barbara sagavski also
found no evidence of widespread voter
fraud and complaints filed by the state
republican party
one area where the pair disagreed was
what to do about inflation both blamed
current president biden brown wants to
aggressively raise interest rates
when we have a runway inflation that is
the highest it's been in over 40 years
that they should be raising rates at two
and a half points or more
immediately to try and combat that
washington has a spending problem it's
it's probably long had us
definitely long had a spending problem
but in the last few years
we've seen trillions of dollars come
down the pipe but what is usually left
off the equation is coded and the
democrats
decided to go the shutdown route
in last week's eight news now the hill
emerson college poll laxalt had a
23-point lead in the primary the winner
of the republican primary faces
incumbent catherine cortez masto in the
general election
nevada's coveted 19 state of emergency
declaration is being lifted next friday
governor steve sisilak made the
announcement during the week the
emergency has been in effect since the
pandemic started more than two years ago
there were just 11 positive cases in
nevada at that time the governor says he
is using the time before the order is
lifted to make sure there are no service
gaps when the state of emergency ends
nevada's two democratic senators joined
republicans in a measure to end mass
mandates for toddlers catherine cortez
masto and jackie rosen voted with five
other democrats to support that senate
resolution this week
abortion on the front stage next on
politics now the vote in the senate on
roe v wade and the next steps for
republicans and democrats
plus opposing ranked choice voting why a
coalition of democrats say they don't
want it
you're watching politics now
a coalition of democratic groups are
campaigning against a ranked choice
ballot initiative the group say ranked
choice voting is complicated confusing
and can lead to more errors the ballot
initiative would also create open
primaries and supporters believe it
encourages more people to vote if
approved you could vote for anyone in a
primary regardless of your registered
political party
this week nevada's two senators both
democrats voted to codify abortion
rights from roe v wade the bill didn't
pass the women's health protection act
only got 49 votes in the senate it
passed the house catherine cortez masto
and jackie rosen supported the measure
senate majority leader chuck schumer
says it is important for lawmakers to
stand against conservative supreme court
justices republicans say the bill
ignores public opinion
if the supreme court follows through on
that decision
it will be the greatest contraction of
individual rights in generations the
american people don't even come close
to supporting abortion on demand up
until the moment of birth
joining us to talk about the failed vote
on women's health protection act is alex
limon from washington dc uh senate
democrats they held a vote trying to
protect abortion rights that americans
have exercised for decades but alex the
vote was kind of doomed to fail from the
start so why have the vote anyway
well senate majority leader chuck
schumer said that he wanted to get every
single senator on the record about where
they stand on abortion rights you know
democrats say that if the supreme court
does in fact strike down roe and the
protections it provides then that would
be the biggest contraction of individual
rights handed down by the court really
ever as opposed to an expansion of
rights and so senator schumer
specifically was looking to get people
like senators lisa murkowski and susan
collins on the record about this because
they have four years said and campaigned
on being pro-choice yet the two of them
um said they would oppose this bill and
then in fact did vote against the
women's health protection act and so
that was one of the things that senator
schumer was looking to do now keep in
mind that even if those two senators had
voted with democrats
there still wasn't enough support for
the bill for it to pass in the senate
democrat joe manchin voted against it
and they just don't have the 60 votes
they need to surpass the filibuster does
the fact democrats might not hold the
majority much longer create more
pressure for the dems to do something
now
well abortion is definitely going to be
an election issue i mean there is a fair
amount of pressure since democrats hold
slim majorities in the senate at least
to try to do something now but
realistically they don't have a large
enough majority to be able to do it and
now does it create pressure for example
for them to campaign on and maybe win
some seeds if they think that's a way
they can do it
maybe um on the flip side you know i've
heard some question whether it creates
pressure for them to compromise with
republicans in order to like you said
get something passed but the things that
republicans are proposing for example
senator lindsey graham has a 20-week
abortion bill which would allow
abortions up to 20 weeks and then ban
them after that with exemptions for
exceptions for rape and incest if it's
reported to police
and also if the mother's health is at
risk
i don't know that democrats see their
base as being supportive of a compromise
like that they say they don't see that
as a
a compromise they're willing to make
because they see that more as an
abortion ban a 20-week ban as opposed to
you know roe which is a legalized
abortion more widely
and that was alex simone from washington
d.c
the first public congressional hearings
on ufos in 50 years we'll talk about
that next on politics now
days on cbs
[Music]
in what to watch we're keeping an eye on
the first public congressional hearing
on ufos in 50 years this will take place
tuesday in a house intelligence
subcommittee hearing the focus is on the
pentagon's
144-page report on unidentified aerial
phenomena it's a subject we've covered
for decades here at channel 8 of course
where we'll have the highlights of the
hearing coming up next week on politics
now and monday night the clark county
school board meets to approve its final
budget we're waiting to see if extra
money is allocated for school security
and teacher pay incentives we'll have
the latest from the school board coming
up next week as well plus we'll continue
to profile the races for the open with
for the seats on the board of trustees
three very interesting races on the
horizon
that'll do it for us here on politics
now we thank you so much for joining us
this week stay up-to-date online with
all the political news all across clark
county and across nevada on a newsnow
dot com we're back with you next
saturday take care
[Music]
you